if you think digital photography has
gotten good over the last few years you
don't know the half of it
this is the Hasselblad CF V 50 C and it
turns empty cameras into high-res
digital shooters Hasselblad makes medium
and large format cameras which use
bigger film and sensors than your usual
35 millimeter or compact shooter the CF
V 50 C is a new digital back that can
take the place of the analog film
magazine on almost any Hasselblad dating
back to the 1950s this lets users take
full advantage of older bodies and
lenses inside the simple box is a 50
megapixel sensor which results in final
images with more than six times as much
resolution as what the iPhone 6 can turn
out they're so big that you have to use
Hasselblad proprietary focus software to
process them and you're also going to
want a big pile of compact flash cards
to store them if you've never shot
medium format before it's nothing like
using any other kind of camera the
equipment is big and heavy and don't
even think about trying to rely on
things like autofocus you have to [ __ ]
the shutter set your exposure focus and
then shoot sure it's laborious but it
really feels like you're making the
picture happen which is a surprisingly
powerful feeling in an age of screen
tapping snapshots side by side the
photographs that come out of the
Hasselblad are incredible details are
razor sharp color fidelity is spot-on
and you can pull tiny details out of
larger compositions without losing a
thing even as someone who shot some of
the best cameras on earth I was
surprised just how good these images
were the kicker this bat comes with a
fifteen thousand five hundred dollar
price tag in the world of digital large
format photography this is totally
reasonable but getting a full setup with
a back body and a nice lens or two just
gonna set you back at least twenty
thousand dollars if you're a
professional photographer have a
collection of vintage Hasselblad gear
sitting in your attic or just crazy
about photography and have the cash to
spare the cfv fifty C can be a good way
to update your kit but for most people
it's probably best to admire from afar
you